how have you seen things changed other
than sort of the delivery of some of
these films and how we're watching
things more at home in our computers but
from your time when you were at the
hollywood reporter for the year and a
half how have you seen things change i
think the changes in the Hollywood
community are only reflect the changes
in the large community in our country
people are less well-educated our school
systems are not educating people the way
that they used to attention span has
really changed storytelling needs to
keep up with that there's a me okay
pretty boys and pretty girls have always
come to town and always welcome to town
the ones who are trained will have
careers the ones who are not trained for
the most part will fall by the wayside I
think that that that you know the studio
system used to train its actors I have a
friend named Virginia leaf who's in her
80s it was a fox contract actress with
Marilyn Monroe and Joanne Woodward and
they worked daily shooting scenes being
trained learned how to learning how to
work on film I think television provides
a lot of that to some degree but the
talent pool has changed I think there
are a lot of people here who really
aren't writers who are writing but not
it seems to me that the real riders who
are younger now are being drawn into
cable television
rather than feature films
you